did you engage in a treatment so I did
not do any of the psychedelics that I
was reporting on but in our third
segment we uh we highlight something
where people are where a psychedelic
experience is induced but without
ingesting anything and I took part in
that and I will tell you breathing it's
through intense breath work and I will
tell you I had a transcendental
experience it was unbelievable and what
was astounding was I did it using this
powerful tool that we all have which is
our own breath I mean I have this here
on my wrist breathe to remind me of that
that is a way to get back to Center and
so the mind is such a
powerful um element of treatment but we
often turn to medicines instead that's
right and I think that so many people
become Gravely ill physically because
they're harboring so much trauma or
Darkness inside that they have not been
able to release or expel and for some
people for whom
psychedelics work this allows them to be
able to do that to purge themselves of
the trauma and new neurop pathways are
created in which to be able to process
it better again it's imperative that you
talk to a professional yes but if you do
go down that T the potential is really
real and taking the stigma out and
opening one's mind to the possibilities
or if that's not for you knowing that
there's a breath work alternative that's
right and um I actually met someone um
who is a warden in a prison recently and
she said you know at 9:30 our TV is on
in our little office and the show comes
on and there's a brightness to it and I
said could we ever come and visit the
prison um and I was wondering would you
ever go to that prison with
me sure okay I would love to and you're
right drew that they they love daytime
TV in prison once when I was working for
the Oprah show I was reporting inside of
a prison and when I walk on to the yard
an incarcerated man yells yo I just saw
you on
Oprah I mean so I think that they would
love to have a visit by you and look and
we incarcerate more people and us than
anywhere else on Earth and these are
some of the most traumatized people on
the planet who are living Behind Bars
they're human beings exactly can we
please do more together Lisa I would to
join you me too okay thank you so much
that's a date to
prison thank thank you so much the
three-part series the Psychedelic
Renaissance can be found at CBS
morning.com and on the CBS Morning
social Channel as well as YouTube
wherever you need to find it it will be
there and thank you Lisa so much more
we'll be right
[Music]
back